the topic of President Donald Trump and
dementia is a topic that just seems to
not go away and it's definitely not
going to go away after his very bizarre
slurring of speech and appearing to have
a tongue ten times it's normal size or
just a very very strange series of
events during his speech yesterday about
recognizing Jerusalem as the Israeli
capital and if you haven't been
following the back story on Trump
dementia there has been speculation for
some time based on a variety of
different incidents involving Donald
Trump that it's possible possible that
he may be in the early stages of
dementia possibly Alzheimer's one
particular type of dementia that there
could be other cognitive limitations may
be related to decline in Donald Trump
questions about his often on lack of
reading abilities sort of unclear and
earlier this week I told you about
Morning Joe host Joe Scarborough from
MSNBC who said that during the campaign
people that were close to Trump told him
that yeah Donald Trump is in the early
stages of dementia some of the strange
things that Donald Trump has done that
have grown speculation about this
include leaving signing events an entire
event is put together for Donald Trump
to sign a bill or an executive order and
Trump leaves the event without actually
signing what he was there to sign
another instance where Donald Trump
stood directly in front of his car the
car waiting to take him to who knows
where the next event and didn't realize
it and started walking away from the car
looking for his car until a Secret
Service agent or other aide kind of
turned Trump back in the direction of
his vehicle not realizing in two
different events that Rudy Giuliani and
his wife Melania Trump were in front of
and next to him respectively this very
very long list and yesterday this video
comes to my attention from Matt which
has only fueled even more speculation
about possible Donald Trump dementia and
I'll tell you after we look at the video
and Matt's email to begin with what I
think is going on here so Matt wrote to
me saying hey David in this last press
briefing by Donald Trump he's
starts out normal but near the end it
looks like he's either chewing on
something or his tongue is swelling up
it really weirded me out and seems like
something you may be interested in
checking out you can scrub through the
video to see the progression at the end
it's almost like he has chewing tobacco
in his mouth so I'm gonna show you two
parts of the video ok first part is
audio during Donald Trump speaking
second one is when Donald Trump is
signing ok so I'll describe that one
piece by piece I'm first going to play
for you the end of Donald Trump's speech
yesterday and this is again a speech
about recognizing Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel and eventually moving
the US Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem we talked about the political
aspect of this story yesterday and what
you'll notice when listening to this is
that Donald Trump starts to sound sort
of Mushmouth slurring his speech
generally sounding weird and if you're
watching as you listen you'll also
notice that Donald Trump starts to look
very odd visibly having difficulty
talking sort of like his tongue is
swelling up huge in his mouth as Matt
suggested in his email to me or imagine
having like an oversized gigantic wad of
chewing gum in your mouth
generally Trump had a look about him
during this portion of the speech that I
would describe as seeming like confusion
person his lips pushing his jaw out
weirdly combined with particularly
strange sniffling even for Donald Trump
let's take a look let's take a listen
and it is time for young and modern
voices all across the Middle East to
claim for themselves a bright and
beautiful future so today let us
rededicate ourselves to a path of mutual
understanding and respect
let us rethink old assumptions and open
our hearts and minds to possible and
possibilities and finally I ask the
leaders of the region political and
religious Israeli and Palestinian Jewish
and Christian and Muslim to join us in
the noble quest for lasting peace thank
you god bless you god bless israel god
bless the palace
minions and God bless the United States
thank you very much thank you okay so
it's it's weird right and the truth is I
know people who have or have had forms
of dementia including Alzheimer's and
this was often how they spoke but at the
same time my grandmother spoke like this
for a while before she passed away and
in her case it was her dentures that
were slipping which is something that's
been proposed here as well now that's
bad enough but then it gets arguably
even worse and in the second part which
we're going to play for you but it
doesn't really have audio you'll notice
that as Donald Trump is signing he's
doing a lot of the same things he looks
at what he's about to sign and he seems
a little bit confused as he's signing it
his jaw kind of hangs weirdly his cheeks
puff up the swollen tongue thing seems
to happen again he does the person of
the lips he looks like he's chewing on
something once again all very very
strange behavior and this is all
completely speculative nothing has as of
yet been said about what what happened
here but there could be a number of
explanations idea number one is okay
could this be connected to dimension
that that's a possibility and we don't
know the answer what other explanations
are there more benign ones I guess we
could say dentures slipping keeps coming
up and that's possible right it's I
don't know whether Donald Trump has
dentures I'm not totally sure whether
some of the other stuff that he's doing
is indicative of dentures slipping but
it's certainly possible it's also been
mentioned that that these may be the
signs of a stroke which would be
horrific I don't know the answer to that
and then drug use is also coming up more
and more now drug use doesn't have to
mean it doesn't necessarily mean
recreational or illicit drugs it could
be side effects from pharmaceutical
drugs may be causing what's often known
as cotton mouth or dry mouth or
something else what we do know is this
is truly strange public rehab behavior
from the President of the United States
of America and I want to be super clear
about this Pat if any of these
speculations are true whether it's
stroke dementia or whatever none of this
is something to be made fun of right
we're talking about medical conditions
here
but it would be concerning in terms of
this person being President of the
United States even if it was just
denture slipping I mean that wouldn't be
something to make fun of either of
course it would just be nice to know
maybe if he had them I mean I'm sure he
would assert that he is the best oral
hygiene
we know it has dentures we yeah and I
looked that up today just to see do we
know whether Donald Trump has dentures
it's clear from his teeth that those are
not his natural teeth they are perfect
and white in every way and they're
they're clearly either veneers or
something could be a full set of
dentures we just don't know and a white
house they had said that it was dry
mouth
yeowch in that case why not just pull a
Rubio grab some water real quick at some
point you could have a sip of water or
something yeah so anyway this is not
helping all of the speculation that
already exists about the possible
cognitive decline of Donald Trump the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership